hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to factorial with Bob
hi Bob hey how's it going hi we're doing
good
I don't mean to speak for you Bob yeah
yeah I don't know how if you're doing
good or not I just wanted to sassoon
that we were doing okay it's going well
man oh yeah not be going well I don't
know you know just in consideration of
everybody I just didn't want to speak
for you anyway so this down here is the
level 1 Factory it looks like it is
choking on gears so we probably need
this on gears as well so we know it's
it's lacking gear oh there's not enough
yes and we do eventually need more iron
and copper funneling into these machines
but that's fine because we got plenty of
science where we're currently trying to
get flight and [ __ ] going on which is
like the main thing that we're going for
now I should take down all of my
production stuff so I can stop staring
at it
yes no no it's like a legacy leave it
there it's important for us to remember
far we have come that one made 37
science yeah I just got science out of
that look at that yeah it were about
that and you know it's pretty good it's
technically making science and I don't
know why this guardian wall is still
here what all the very important very
delicate assembly machines are on the
outside of the walls no longer really
appropriate or useful it's protecting
history like this is a history museum
since our historic district well I
didn't well I didn't have any part of
this place like this see how lead up it
is that's how you can tell it's historic
it's dumb and old and stupid just like
the people that made it I'm old and
stupid Arnie you're aren't you older
than me am I yeah probably by a little
bit June 28th um I'm turning 27 June
20th yeah you your birthdays later in
the year October October yeah so I don't
don't ask my dad oh god what happened ah
nothing we're we under hey I ruined my
highly functional um
assembly line for a moment there no okay
all right all right so I say what we
should do next is we should go down and
show these bastards they
should mess with our land sounds good
sounds right maybe I don't know how
effective I'm gonna be when I'm lagging
all over the place but we're gonna go
down there and we're gonna kick some ass
are you sure they have up I broke
everything again hang on
goddamnit picnic Oh my fault I'm just
stupid it sounds exactly like your fault
connects nice I just walled myself out
how will I ever get back inside the wall
you're gone you're probably already
infected oh geez
fix-it everybody hey hey I'm here
no I'm gonna go over here where the
aliens are alright so what we're gonna
do is we're gonna go over to this alien
bastard encampment we're gonna blow the
[ __ ] out of their faces so we should
like bring its hurt with us or something
I got a dirt did you not bring a turret
I'm gonna build my own while we're
walking over there
okay good man good plan will formulate
it on you good plan good man plan man
good plan man okay so there's I see a
lot of movement I like that we're doing
this at night this feels like a good
strategy yeah probably the best strategy
we're gonna kill these [ __ ] dead are
they coming for us I can't even tell I
don't I'm gonna place a turret like
right here as they fall back a little
bit to the north of you no no place it
closer we're just gonna try to inch
closer to these these ass okay so we'll
have like leaf rocking vases yeah so
it's just a small one oh my god it's
fine fine oh god oh god I'm lagging I'm
like it okay it's fine see everything
was fine I'm still shooting at nothing
everything's fine alright so now I'm
gonna move your turd up closer now and
so we can have a little bit of a
leapfrog okay cool
alright I can fire upon the enemy I'm
firing upon the enemy back attack and
see it dies you Oh God
come at me bro 'he's a sea alien
artifacts and you pick them up and
that's goo so now i've a lien artifacts
done all right I pick up mine Oh what
electric engines finished I'm gonna
research flight narshe flight means no
getting both side we're gonna research
from way the hell far away like research
your there's no one in the labs they're
just a series of Rube Goldberg machines
trying to get everything going together
just science by algorithm oh sweet Jesus
oh sweet oh I'm trying to put ammo in
here oh god I'm gonna cover you I'll
cover you I'll cover you move now move
ah damn it
did you die I died oh [ __ ] why didn't
you cover me I was [ __ ] trying it was
trying to god damn it I'm all the way
out here I got nothing damn it all my
[ __ ] just exploded all over the place
you should spawn pretty close to the
base yeah but all my [ __ ] got exploded
have to break down this wall with my
bare hands
I climb with my broken fingernails and
just desperately trying I'm gonna I need
to go get more iron and copper and [ __ ]
this [ __ ] you have [ __ ] me you'll
[ __ ] you lated me I didn't do anything
to you I I made for your problem I blame
you anyway just because I can
this copper is out of control alright
okay I'm slowly very laga SH Lee coming
back well I'm still assaulting these
spaces so Oh No
I'll finish I'll finish what we started
I know I'm coming I I wanted to start
this so I wanted to finish it this was
your idea
that's correct hang on hang on hang on
[ __ ] okay hang on I'm just trying to go
in one direction if I just push myself
in one way the lag will eventually carry
me over okay you make it no Shannon
would know I mean I did not have very
much ammo with me why did he make more
oh okay cuz I don't think ahead I'm
making a shotgun I'm carving a shotgun
out of the trees around me
I'm fashioning it with sticks it's gonna
be super effective weapon just you
okay all right on the way I'm a-comin I
just assaulted two more nests and our
turrets are both at half health but
that's fine no that's fine
where are you no I'm back out in the
same direction
okay um ah man I'm coming along the way
you bring any iron with you cuz I could
really use
I brought 160 awesome I'll make a wood
chest
I'll put it after I get done making a
bajillion shotgun shells hang on I'm
just canceling those okay and Blanc long
Co I got a chest here well too late just
fine there we go oh man this lag is
unreal good
it's unfuckin here you can have your
turbek we'll each have one
thank you it took a little damage it's
okay it's okay alright do we want to
assault one more base is this gonna go
well for me it didn't go well for me
last time I distinctly remember be fine
we just need to put our turrets down
more aggressively yeah I'm not wait wait
so we're already being overrun oh
they're coming they're coming again it's
only for you it just don't shoot me I'm
trying all right I'm gonna put one here
I'm gonna fill it with I have no ammo
for it so I'm slowly gonna make ammo for
it and then it's gonna be good I can put
some help no I got it's got two
magazines ah I was fine
alright here they come ah [ __ ]
lag oh sweet cheese hanging like let's
move left move left huh okay we're fine
I'm gonna move mine in move yours up and
okay are you planning it alright it's
gonna be in the middle of the woods
right oops oh geez I lagged forward mo
mo mo mo mo general journal darkness mo
mo mo okay you're good I'm fine mo mo
thing's fine I can't oh god it there's
ammo in it I can't I'm still moving oh
god the lag so bad the trees the trees
ruined everything
why trees no the trees haven't ruin
anything okay
here they come Oh God I'm trying to make
repair packs to fix up my my thing did
you know you can make repair packs and
repair things I did
and I did know that I think I'm out of
stuff to make repair packs they just a
little iron it ain't no big deal okay so
now we can assault this base with
confidence repair packs I got you I got
you boo
don't worry boo all right got you thank
you you are welcome okay now that's a
fancy looking one yeah that one's got
more that one's got more artifacts ow ow
ow
well oh man I need to move mine closer
hang on we need to get the turrets
closer got it okay it's it's coming in
turret flying in turret turret loaded up
okay turtle oded all right we're good
mine in closer now we got it now we got
it now we got it yeah they're trying to
biopsy the base
yeah that's tough yeah baby murdering
local wildlife as is our desire I don't
know [ __ ] I'm still shooting I was just
shooting it was lack shootin it wasn't
me become good myself I'm a monster ha
it's okay mark everyone already knew
that I just can't hold down the button
because that's the problem I think I
think that's what's [ __ ] everything
up like holding down hey we did it man
we did it I've got a run 35 Aryan
artifacts nice now once we get more
stuff that big a base to the north
no North the big base isn't north north
is gonna be next on our bucket list to
kill it's gonna be next stop for us yes
us eco-terrorist we come to an alien
world and we ravage the local population
yeah with our giant tail whatever you'll
never see me coming
in yeah yeah that was kind of like nerdy
Macho Man Randy Savage I was trying to
do I was trying to do I'll never see me
coming
oh sure everything slowed down I was
trying to do nerdy nerdy um uh what'd
you call it the Mandarin from Iron Man 3
oh yeah you were your capitalist society
is crumbling to act around you you will
never see me come
yeah something like that that intimidate
it yeah yeah okay cool thanks thanks man
thank you
dead-on thank you tried really hard
all right 147 regular science how much
big sense yes uh we got 126 science - I
feel like the science - should be making
more but I think there's a choke hold
somewhere in there okay I think it's
short on inserters it looks like
probably it looks like there are just
not a lot of inserters going out oh I
think it's choking up on circuit boards
- no it's got plenty of circuit boards
there's no okay I think it's got too
many I think oh I got you the the
inserter creators can't place anything
because what actually there's oh wait
the gear the gear maker isn't working
why is the gear maker not working oh oh
it needs more iron it's just we
literally just need more iron that's the
only thing that's it's running out of
iron that's it okay so I'm going to
increase iron output over there ah
okay so there's yeah this is fine easy
peasy take nether that back up a copper
dam
yeah I know the copper is copper for
days copper is ludicrous right now add a
control copper I don't care and then
make I'm going to make a fast
another earn all dough to go out here
and there's gonna pump out way more way
more
oh [ __ ] like more it's pumping all of it
so we need we more or I need more a [ __ ]
I'm out of stone I lost everything god
damn it and like absolutely punch a
stone in the chest I got it no there's a
bunch of wall in the chests you need
brick or stone stone stone stone if I
got some stone I can give you here geez
I'm stuck I'm stuck hang on I'm stuck
you can put it in the top right okay
thank you okay so I just need to make
more electric mining drills why iron
plate okay
more like your mining drills and then
everything is gonna be kosher this is
quite the little encampment we got going
on here you know it's not bad you know
from what I assumed everyone was
probably doubting that we'd ever get to
this point but you know we're we proved
some people wrong we proved huh look at
the map at the North pollution so you
don't have a lot of time before we're a
[ __ ] we have no northern defenses do we
no I've got some turrets I've got three
four turrets up here by the iron
production yeah no wall or anything I
think in the next episode we need to
refigure our power supplies because that
of the nick of the autofit yeah can we
out of it because this situation I
constantly yeah eventually we're gonna
move to like laser turrets and so we
need like reliable power that keeps us
safe at night yeah whatever well so we
just need to reconfigure the steam
engines into a way and there's a coal
patch right down here we just need to
reconfigure the steam engines into a way
that the coal like maybe on the right
side uh-huh of this body of water okay
yeah get some coal a dedicated cool
supply just for the boilers or is there
a coal supply by the big lake to the
west or the coals only here I think
there's a coal supply in that direction
but there's not one like this one that's
like on the water's edge okay yeah no we
go look all right [ __ ] walled in all
the way no I trust you I trust you I
believe you but my tommy gun does I like
that reference house good luck
the only reason uh there's an oil field
to the oh that's not the main body of
water
oh yeah oil yeah oil we don't need we
don't need steam engines if we have oil
oh there's like one little puddle of oil
out here it's nothing that's enough
there's a big puddle of oil down to the
south do you see that down there like a
big pool or to the north like north by
this coal like there's even more oil
lots of oil okay
well that'll work it's in the middle of
the forest and I'm lagging
way through we just need to do some more
deforestation yeah nasty forestation
ruin sweet sweet crude oil that's to me
those stupid [ __ ] trees did you [ __ ]
those stupid trees and all the animals
that live there like just so many Asian
leaves its dimensions as is and
transition into engines for power
yeah like generators maybe that's nice
yeah probably I mean I wouldn't just
like immediately [ __ ] the steam engines
get those [ __ ] out of here like we can
we can run everything the minute your
media leaf um leave them in place but
like you just don't go through the whole
her [ __ ] of recur jiggering them and
feeding them with coal if we're just
gonna switch off to other power sources
anyway yeah that's probably true is you
can pipe oil from I mean you just need
pipes to move oil around to your
fineries and then directly into the
engines probably right yeah and then we
can use pipe underground
I've already some as you saw and Curley
employed to make sure that my water
supply was safe front from what exactly
what is your water supplies are feeding
[ __ ] aliens that's the that's the
alien ship entered NES game what okay
I'm sorry Bob again I'm questioning your
incredible logic and brainpower here I'm
sorry I should know better at this point
you are the glorious leader that we all
follow into I'm the one who thought of
all this [ __ ] I know I know you are it's
true you are the greatest ever in the
entire world
like literally of the two people on this
planet you're the best they call me fake
boobs Bob dude do they call you big
boobs Bob and who because again I'm the
only other person on this planet so that
would mean that I call you big boobs Bob
I actually in a book club with some of
the aliens and oh it's not it's not
you're not invited sorry oh wow okay all
right
told me that um they've seen your
YouTube videos uh-huh through space
uh-huh
yeah stuff and you're not invited so
okay all right well if I kill all the
[ __ ] aliens and then
have no one else to book club that's you
and I would have to have a book all
right I better be right back to lack my
wind-up Jess I die horribly in the
middle of nothing God
okay when you get rid of all these trees
this land is so useful yeah I know have
trees stupid we could as you could have
started out in a desert biome that would
have made things way easier but no you
had to get in a lush forest berries get
some pump jacks going yeah I don't even
know how to do that oh yes it is pump
I'm just gonna craft some pump jacks and
see what happens all right I'm believing
it also I think we also need some
logistical stuff like also yeah I'm
gonna work on the oil refinery I need
just a little more stone brick right
yeah I'm gonna go get some more iron so
that I have some iron
uh-huh oh there's like sonic in here oh
my gosh there's 100 there's so much iron
literally oh Christ there's way too much
iron we went overboard on the iron and
actually when we get the plastics in
place which we're getting from soil we
should do is oil off also for the
plastics but we are going to have um
watching we call it's watching my
doo-dads uh super electric furnaces yeah
electric furnaces which means we don't
need to feed them with coal anymore and
they can just double up on the iron nice
duper electric furnaces super-dee-duper
is the technical term for the electrical
furnaces you get it right lib that's
cool okay then Lee what's making 1.1 K
pipes off I need that many how much I
wrap that might be overkill there is uh
there's other research options that also
allow us to handle that stuff better but
I don't know advanced oil processing or
something heavy oil cracking delight oil
what the hell does that mean what does
that mean heavy oil cracking to light
oil obviously oh okay
it means just I get I should have known
I'm sorry anyway that's all the time for
this episode so I guess we're done here
so
thank you everybody so much for watching
in the next episode we'll have oil
production on our to-do list and we will
get it done real good so thank you
everybody and as always we'll see you in
the next video bye-bye so grab the
hunting rifles and we make our way
confidently and naked ly over to Boise